let's go next to our caller from the
6:08 area code who is calling today from
6:08 hello David
this is Jack hey Jack what's up okay so
there's this thing I would go to the
college and I'm a liberal in my college
um I see a lot of Trump supporters in my
college and it seems the reason for that
is because they hate the regressive less
and they don't really understand much
about other issues and they just get
droven driven further to the right
because of the left in their social
justice warrior you know how that is so
I just wondering what are your thoughts
on that and how can I talk to a trump
supporter that just hates the left
because of that and want to offer them a
new perspective so listen here's the
unfortunate reality and I address this a
couple weeks ago a little bit when I did
an audience question about what happened
to the anti SJW movement because the
reality is that there has always been a
sliver of the left that is obsessed with
identity politics to an unhealthy degree
for example right or whatever whatever
you want to talk like whatever slice
you're referring to that people at your
college are sick of that has existed for
a long time they became a target of the
alt-right and of so-called free speech
movements on the right for a little
while and they got some traction from it
and then it sort of started to fade and
then it became less of a thing so I
think that the most important thing in
my mind to engage with people on on the
right is show them that the people that
have been out there fear-mongering
about so-called sjw's are are lying to
them they are not honestly representing
that that is a tiny fraction of the left
that does not represent the big ideas of
the left in any way and try to get them
to see that they've been bamboozled by
whoever it is that came to the campus or
whose videos they watched on YouTube
convince them that this is a big problem
is it a problem sure I mean like it
exists and I've spoken out against it
but they don't have a controlling stake
in the left at this point in time they
don't have a controlling stake in the
narrative and it's it's it's sad
actually that a lot of people get sucked
into these echo chambers when we're
really talking about a very small sliver
of the left that's the reality yeah and
I actually like I talked to these people
that say they're conservative and they
seem just to hate sjw's but when I talk
to them about individual issues right
they're liberal yeah like they're
they're liberal when it comes to gun
control when it comes to health care
when it comes to when it comes to
foreign policy it's just that the fact
of those those sjw's just make them go
right because they just can't stand it
yep absolutely they're pointing this out
perfectly which is an issue on issues
there's no reason for them to be
supporting Donald Trump and it's oh it's
a horrible propaganda campaign that
worked pretty well for a while but I
have to tell you I think it is starting
its effectiveness has started to wane
and hopefully will continue - all right
David that's really all I had to ask you
about all right very good thank you so
much for the call yeah I appreciate you
calling it